hey guys today we will be doing a list
of the 20 oldest monsters and beings in
fiction which would include movies
animated series games and more we know
that we are going to miss out on some of
your favorites so do comment' the ones
that we did not include and we will
research and maybe make a part two based
on how many there are
anyway let us start with the list number
20 smart from the 2013 movie hobbit the
desolation of smaug smart was a
firedrake of the Third Age considered to
be the last great dragon to exist in
middle-earth he was drawn towards the
enormous wealth amassed by the dwarves
of the Lonely Mountain during the reign
of King thrall and laid waste to the
neighbouring city of Dale and captured a
Lonely Mountain for 171 years Smok
hoarded the lonely mountains treasures
to himself staying within the mountain
it was said that the dragon was a young
dragon when he entered the Lonely
Mountain and so this would make him
easily over 200 years old in age after
the 171 years of hibernating inside
Erebor number 19 Thanos from Avengers
infinity war and endgame Thanos was a
genocidal warlord from Titan whose own
main objective was to bring stability to
the universe as he believed its massive
population was inevitably used of the
universe's entire supply of resources
and condemned ninh to complete this goal
Terrence set about tracking down the
Infinity stones as the combined might
would wipe out half the universe as
stated by the director of the movie in
one of them interviews Tallis was at
least 1000 years old but could have been
much more older and number 18 comes to
creeper from Jeepers Creepers movies The
Creeper is a fictional character and the
main antagonist in the 2001 horror film
jeepers creepers and its sequels jeepers
creepers 2 and their inter quilled
jeepers creepers 3 it is an ancient
mysterious demon who seeks out organs
from humans to replace its own old or
damaged ones it hunts for 23 days every
twenty-third of spring by scaring its
victims and using the scent of fear to
determine what it needs to feed on the
master is easily
over 2000 years old and seems to be
immortal number 17 ends a burner from
the 2016 x-men apocalypse and summoner
was born nearly 5000 years ago in lone
settlement in the very edge of the ax
mentor in the very edge of the valley of
the kings in ancient Egypt as new guru
he supports the other tribesmen in
intelligence and strength everyone in
the tribe
except for Baal hated and feared nor for
his inhuman looks and great abilities he
was one of the first mutants and was
worshipped as a God in ancient Egypt he
was later trapped during a ritual and
was reawakened in 1983 and was finally
defeated by the Phoenix force and he was
5,000 years old then and number 16 comes
to White Walkers from the Game of
Thrones the White Walkers were an
ancient race of formerly human ice
creatures who came from the far north of
Westeros the White Walkers were 8,000
years old coming in from the time
preceding the Age of Heroes born of
powerful and untested magic they were
created to protect the children of the
forest from the first men however the
White Walkers eventually broke free of
the chills control and became one of the
most feared creatures in Westeros posing
a threat to anything living number 15
argument from Warcraft games Archimonde
was the left hand of the fallen Titan
Sargeras Archimonde was one of the
greatest and darkest of the arid aah his
ruthless and cunning personality quickly
earned him station and power within the
elder ranks until finally he was one of
the first among them he is described as
one of the lieutenant's and Generals of
the demon Titan Sargeras Archimonde is
easily over 25,000 years old as he was
already a narrator leader those many
years ago before being corrupted by the
demon Titan number 14 the god Emperor of
mankind from the game Warhammer 40k the
Emperor of mankind is the immortal
perpetual and a God who serves as a
ruling monarch of the Imperium of man
the chaos gods and the demons of the war
referred to him as the anathema for he
is the greatest embodiment of the
universal order in a galaxy today as the
karien law of the Imperium for whom a
thousand souls are sacrificed each days
so that he may never truly die
Emperor of mankind has its origins in
Anatolia in 8000 BC and so in the 41st
millennium he is over 48 thousand years
old at number 13 comes Sauron from The
Hobbit and Lord of the Rings movies
Sauron was one of the mightiest of the
Maya originally of owls people he had
quite great scientific knowledge of the
world substances and how to use them he
would retain his knowledge throughout
his tenure as Dark Lord servant Sauron
also seemed to be primarily linked with
the use of fire and as Marvel's chief
lieutenant his ability to tap into the
fires in the earth was of great value
the mire like Sauron were older than
planet ardor so he is over fifty five
thousand years old since that is the age
of the world importance works number 12
Surtur from the movie thor ragnarok
Serra was the rule of Muspelheim
prophesized to be the one to initiate
Ragnarok serda was successfully defeated
by Odin who stole from him the source of
his power the eternal flame before
banishing him and his entire race to
Muspelheim in Ragnarok it is mentioned
that Odin defeated Surtur half a million
years ago and was not seen again since
then and he was older than Odin so he
could be easily over a million years old
number 11 Optimus Prime in the IDW
comics born as Orion Pax the Robot
eventually known as Optimus Prime would
rise slowly but surely to fame first as
a law officer unafraid to stand up for
justice then as a great and powerful
military leader who led the line against
Megatron's Decepticons
on Cybertron and across the galaxy as
the first legitimate prime in many ages
heir to the matrix of leadership Optimus
Prime is revered by many and reviled by
some but always as a powerful presence
in and out of battle in this timeline he
is around four to six million years old
number 10 precursors from the Pacific
Rim universe precursors are a race of
colonizing aliens from the anti verse
and the creators of the kaiju
they are spindly creatures who stand
over 12 feet tall and are capable of
living for millions of years because
time flows differently in the anti verse
their appearance is akin to that of an
aquatic insect
they have translucent wings and
shell-like bodies that revealed an
internal system in 2013 Neri opened the
portal to earth established during the
Triassic period maybe around 210 million
years ago as during that time the co2
levels were pretty low and they needed a
high co2 level to survive in so we can
easily say that the precursor species
have been present for at least 210 or
250 million years ago during the
Triassic period number 9 Godzilla and
the other Titans from the monsters
franchise the king of the monsters was
given a radically new origin story that
deviates from the previously established
origin of him being mutated by the
hydrogen bomb in Godzilla awakening the
prequel to Godzilla Godzilla is
explained to be an ancient life form
from the Permian period he and the other
Titans from Earth's hibernated and fed
upon earth thermal radiation for
millions of years following the loss of
radiation in the Earth's surface he's
thought to be around 250 million years
old
number 8 destoroyah from the Toho Heisei
timeline Destroyer is a crustacean kaiju
created by Toho that first appeared in a
1995 Godzilla film Godzilla vs.
destoroyah and as the film's main
antagonist des rois received his name
from the film when dr. Eugene witnesses
the monsters juvenile forms merged
together into their aggregate form he
remarks that the micro oxygen does not
have that kind of power
and that these creatures have become the
living oxygen destroyer giving it the
name destoroyah but these tiny
microorganisms are mutated into
destoroyah were over 540 million years
old at number 7 we get the graboids from
the tremors franchise grabar is a
fictional invertebrate species that is
the primary antagonist of the tremors
franchise the creature made its debut in
the 1990 film tremors
graboids are depicted as subterranean
animals superficially resembling
gigantic worms and larvae with long
serpentine bodies when fully grown a
mature American graboid can measure up
to 30 feet long and 6 feet across at its
widest point and may weigh around 10 to
20 tons these animals appeared
around 600 million years ago at number
six we have the engineers from the
xenomorph universe the engineers are
also known as pilots after the
individual discovered on lv-426 or also
as space jockeys they are an ancient
extraterrestrial species of unknown
origin they possess some of the most
advanced technology in the entire galaxy
with special emphasis placed on their
skills and genetic engineering credited
with the creation of mankind and the
seeding of life on earth billions of
years ago these aliens have a life span
of around 150 years but he have existed
for billions of years and they can
hibernate or be in cryostasis for
thousands of years
number 5 Steppenwolf from the DCE you
Stephanie well from the Justice League
is a new god of apocalypse and the uncle
of drop site he leaves the apocalypse
Ian's army in his nephews honor
Steppenwolf was born billions of years
ago on a distant planet apocalypse as a
new god alongside his nephew Darkseid
who rules over the planet over the years
Stefan Wolfe managed to master his
powers abilities and skills and was
chosen to be the supreme military leader
of the apocalypse in military
Steppenwolf is a tyrant just like his
own nephew and he might have been around
12 or 13 billion years old number 4
Cthulhu from the Call of Cthulhu he is a
great old one of great power that lies
in a deathlike slumber beneath the
Pacific Ocean in his sunken city of Rila
he remains a dominant presence in the
eldritch dealings of our world the most
detailed descriptions of Cthulhu is in
the Call of Cthulhu a base and statues
of the creature one constructed by an
artist after a series of dreams is said
to have he led simultaneous pictures of
an octopus a dragon and a human
calculator he arrived on earth 175
million years ago but his age is close
to the beginning of the universe around
12 to 13 billion years old number 3
Unicron from the Transformers prime
timeline
Unicron is the true main antagonist of
the Transformers Prime before the dawn
of time he's known as the bringer of
chaos
the law of the undead and one of the
main sources of evil in the entire
universe and the very source of dark
Energon as an immortal and eternal being
with immense power your Crone is the
eternal arch enemy of his twin brother
Primus the creator of the transformer
race he was created along Primus around
13 billion years ago
number two the Dark Elves in thought
dark world the MCU Dark Elves are the
oldest known species in existence
hailing from the obscure realm of
survival hime they are one of the
immortal enemies of the Asgardians and
the others are the frost giants some
members of their race the Dark Elves
have been shown to be half the fortitude
to wield the power of an infinity stone
they are now presumed to be critically
endangered as a species or even extinct
though they have been in existence
before the universe came into being
around 13.7 billion years ago or even
older and at the number one spot comes
Galactus from the Marvel Comics Galactus
is the sole survivor of the sixth
incarnation of the multiverse originally
Galactus was a humanoid named Galan born
in the previous incarnation of earth-616
on planet Earth
a paradise like world whose civilization
is said to have been the most advanced
of any of the known universe of that
time however the sixth Infinity and all
its universes were in the final stages
of collapse due to the multiverse
renewal cycle so everything was recycled
except for him who survived the fall and
so he holds the top spot as being the
oldest being or monster in this list and
yes with that comes the end of the list
and we could have missed out on a lot
more and do hope that you would comment
on another list for us to make as a part
2 anyway do like share and subscribe for
more videos related to monsters guide
you and more